yharnam is a dangerous place but a good
weapon at your side can make all the
difference with love borns latest patch
it's a lot easier to take your hunter
axes and holy blades to max level the
pleasant outside or knock yourself to
begin taking your weapons to level 10
requires a Bloodrock and prior to patch
1.09 you could only get one from the
base game plus an extra from the old
hunter's DLC now you'll be able to
purchase them for 60 inside a pop after
clearing a certain part of the game it's
expensive but it should make that whole
upgrading thing much easier the patch
brings a few other changes including
strength and stamina costs for multiple
weapons the price of bloodstone chunks
has also dropped from 30 insight to 20
blood-borne might still be the hardest
game you play in 2015 but these changes
should make things just that much easier
blood-borne was awarded our number for
game of the year spot you can check out
the full list of our favorite games at
gamespot.com slash game of the year and
for all video game news you want you'll
already be in the right place